okay let's just take you to the Prime
Minister and jean-claude Juncker
everybody welcome to the Commission
press room for these press conference by
President Juncker Prime Minister may
without further ado I give the floor to
the president Prime Minister ladies and
gentlemen this morning Prime Minister
may and I had the meeting to take stock
the progress since we met on Monday I
will not hide that in between Monday and
this morning we had a lot of talks the
prime minister myself for the district
and myself that I forgot the Prime
Minister and that's reason why I would
like to thank the Prime Minister for
determination I would also like to thank
Michelle Varney and David Davies as well
as their teams for the extremely hard
and skillful work over the last weeks
and months we discussed the joint report
agreed by the two negotiators from mr.
may has assured me that it has backing
of the UK government on that basis I
believe we have now made the work food
we needed today's result is of course
the compromise it is the result of a
long and intense discussion between the
Commission negotiations and those of the
UK as in any negotiation both sides had
to listen to each other
adjust the position and show a
willingness to compromise this was a
difficult negotiation for the European
Union as well as for the United Kingdom
on Wednesday last Wednesday the College
of Commissioners gave me a Monday to
conclude the negotiation of the joint
report and it had to be concluded today
not next week today because next week
will happen
council and in order to allow our
partners to prepare in the best way
possible the meeting of European Council
we had to make the deal today on the
basis of the mandate which was given to
me by the European Council
the Commission has just formally decided
to recommend to the European Council
that sufficient progress has now been
made on the strict terms of the divorce
as food and the new garage which they
had sealed 33 years in despite the
positive element I am thinking current
news upon huge well just while we're
getting that in in French let's just
briefly talk to that mark stone so a
compromise but a breakthrough
okay apologies we can't get hold of art
so let's talk to Tom Rayner our
political correspondent who's in Downing
Street let's talk to him and it's the
same point Tom is that mean he's saying
it is to break through but a compromise
has been reached
jean-claude juncker they're confirming
that the European Commission will
suggest an officially recommended
substantial progress has been made that
the key phrase to move things on to
phase 2 of these negotiations to move
beyond the questions around the divorce
settlement which were of course on EU
citizens rights the Irish border and
that financial settlement on to final
trade talks that has been a key goal of
the UK government through his may very
concern to try and move that on before
the end of the year because domestically
there's all the pressure from the
businesses who are working out whether
or not they need to activate contingency
plans if there are not details in place
for a transition deal so this will be
very good news for the government it's
something they have worked hard for
something they thought they had in place
on Monday until things fell apart but I
think the key Stephan now is what the
terms were all in Foster speaking to
David Blevins
this morning said that six substantive
changes have been made to the agreed
text and while she had still some
reservations about
okay leaves the European Union EU
citizens have made important life
choices on the assumption that the
United Kingdom was a member of the
European Union who actually created
great uncertainty for those citizens and
for their families today we bring back
the certainty the Commission's
negotiators have made sure that the
choice is made by the new citizens
living in the UK will be protected we
have made sure that their rights will
remain the same after the UK has left
the European Union this is in particular
the case for EU citizens right to live
work and study
EU citizens right to family
identification the protection of the
right of English citizen children and
the right to health care pensions and
other Social Security benefits we are
made sure that the Administrative
Procedures will be cheap and will be
simple this is an issue for which the
Commission with a particular pay
particular attention when drafting the
withdrawal agreement the same goes for
UK citizens living in the 27 on the
setting of accounts the prime minister
said in a remarkable foreign speech that
United Kingdom would honor its
commitments including beyond 2020 this
was detailed
line by line process but she has been as
good as what she was negotiating in a
gentleman man and I'm very grateful
Prime Minister for that on Ireland the U
has consistently supported the goal of
peace and reconciliation enshrined in
the Good Friday Agreement the European
Union has made it a priority to protect
the peace process on the ACT I have been
in regular contact with the tea shop
over the last days including last night
and including
the last negotiations we had because of
yesterday with our Irish friends the UK
has made significant commitments on the
avoidance of a hard border after its
withdrawal from the European Union all
of the eu27 stand firmly behind Ireland
and behind the peace process let me
clear we still have a lot of work to do
the joint report is not the withdrawal
agreement that agreement needs to be
drafted by the negotiators on the basis
we have agreed yesterday and today and
then approved by the council and
ratified by the UK Parliament and the
European part 534 days ago the British
people voted to leave the European Union
2014 nine days ago the United Kingdom
notified its intention to leave the
European Union and in 477 days the
United Kingdom will do just that I will
always be said about this development
but now we must start looking for the
future the future in which the United
Kingdom will be and will remain a close
friend and Ally the Prime Minister and I
discussed the need for a transitional
period and we dedicated much of our
meeting to our joint vision for the deep
and close tab it is crucial for us all
that we continue working closely
together on issues such as straight
research security and others we will
take things one step at a time starting
with next week's European Council but
today I'm hopeful that we are now all
moving towards the second phase of these
challenging negotiations and we can do
this jointly on the basis of trust we
need trust
determination and with the perspective
of the renewed friendship Thank You fun
stories thank you well thank you John
Claude we've been working extremely hard
this week and as you've all seen it
hasn't been easy for either side when we
met on Monday we said our deal was
within reach what we have arrived at
today represents a significant
improvement and I'm grateful to the
negotiating teams led by David Davis and
Michel Barnier for their efforts getting
to this point has required give and take
on both sides and I believe that the
joint report being published is in the
best interests of the whole of the UK I
very much welcome the prospect of moving
ahead to the next phase to talk about
trade and security and to discuss the
positive and ambitious future
relationship that is in all of our
interests I've consistently said that we
want to build a deep and special
partnership with the EU as we implement
the decision of the British people to
leave at the end of March 2019 doing so
will provide clarity and certainty for
businesses in the UK and the EU and
crucially for all our citizens the deal
we've struck will guarantee the rights
of more than 3 million EU citizens
living in the UK and of a million UK
citizens living in the EU EU citizens
living in the UK will have their rights
enshrined in UK law and enforced by
British courts they will be able to go
on living their lives as before I was
clear in Florence that we're a country
that honors our obligations after some
tough conversations we've now agreed a
settlement that is fair to the British
taxpayer it means that in future we will
be able to invest more in our priorities
at home such as housing schools and the
NHS in Northern Ireland we will
guarantee there will be no hard border
and we will uphold the Belfast agreement
and in doing so we will continue to
preserve the constitutional and economic
integrity of the United Kingdom we have
taken this weak time this week to
strengthen and clarify this part of the
agreement following discussions with
unionists in Northern Ireland and across
the UK
the tea shockley Oh vodka and I spoke
yesterday and we've both committed that
there should be no barriers either
north-south or east-west and I believe
this agreement delivers that to
underline the importance of these
principles I'm writing today to the
people of Northern Ireland to set out
our approach millions of jobs depend on
the future trading relationship we will
determine and I'm optimistic about the
discussions ahead but in the meantime
reaching this agreement now ensures that
businesses will be able to make
investment decisions based on an
implementation period but offers
welcomed certainty I will be seeing
president tusk shortly and I look
forward to the publication of his
guidelines I also look forward to next
week's European Council meeting where I
hope and expect we will be able to get
the endorsement of the 27 - what is a
hard-won agreement in all our interests
thank you we have time for some
questions let me start with European
newspaper those who are here in Brussels
Prime Minister this was a difficult
negotiation like you just said very
challenging like the president said but
it's just the beginning the first stage
and it's just the beginning of a very
long and complex negotiation and it was
already very difficult did ever the the
question come to your mind that maybe
after all this whole brexit affair is a
very bad idea for any second thank you
in 2016 the British people were given in
a referendum the opportunity to choose
whether to stay in the European Union or
not Parliament was united across all
parties in Parliament a significant
majority agreed that that decision would
be given to the British people the
British people voted and they voted to
leave the European Union and I believe
it's a matter of trust and integrity in
politicians it means the people should
be able to trust that their politicians
will put into place what they have
determined and in and that's exactly
what we're doing and we will be leaving
the European Union
have Adam from the BBC hi adam fleming
from the BBC morning to both of you
and what is the biggest compromise the
other side has made to get you to this
point today and was at a champagne
breakfast this this was a question
actually is coming together and working
together for a report and agreements
that were in the best interests of all
sides it's been finding the way through
that enables us to deliver for citizens
to deliver on the financial settlement
and also crucially to deliver in
relation to Northern Ireland that
agreement on no hard border but also
respecting the Constitution and economic
integrity of the United Kingdom that's
what we've been working to that's what I
believe this joint report sets out
newsagency
morning mister permit I'm sorry in this
prime minister the arrangement seems to
mean a special status for Northern
Ireland how come at the your partner
they do you P accepted that and will it
not mean that the rest of the UK will
also remain in the single market no it
doesn't actually mean what you've
suggested with very clear if you look at
the agreement at the text of the joint
report it says that we will work to
achieve the relationship the trading
relationship between the UK and the
European Union that we want to see that
we believe will also be the good trading
relationship for Northern Ireland if
that is not the case then we will look
for specific solutions to what are the
unique circumstances of Northern Ireland
everybody recognizes that because
Northern Ireland is the only part of the
UK with a land border with a country
that will be remaining within the
European Union that is a set of unique
circumstances and indeed there are
already unique circumstances and
specific solutions for Northern Ireland
there's a single electricity market
across the island of Ireland for example
but I'm confident that we
in negotiating the future trade
relationship we can ensure that we both
know won't have a hard border in
Northern Ireland but that we will retain
the economic integrity of the single
market of the United Kingdom good good
morning to you both Mark Stone from Sky
News and prime minister could I ask you
in simple terms what has changed between
Monday's lunch and now which allows you
to say that deals done now and you
couldn't on on on Monday and president
Juncker for you if I may specifically on
the European Court of Justice it was one
of the big sticking points the prime
minister says now that EU citizens in
the UK will be under UK law and UK
courts is that correct
are you happy with that on the on the
first point as we said when we stood
here on Monday there were a couple of
issues that we still had to finalise as
we went through the last few days but as
I said in the remarks that I've just
made we have one of the things you can
see is a strengthening of the
commitments in relation to Northern
Ireland in the United Kingdom I think
that's important I think that's helpful
so within the joint report you will see
the commitment both to no heart border
between Ireland and the Northern Ireland
but also that we ensure that we retain
that constitutional integrity and
economic integrity of the United Kingdom
for US citizens the European Court of
Justice will still be competent Michel
Barnier will explain you later on in
detail what is this about because it
could take too much time to explain this
indeed
[Music]
thank you